if you're looking for a little extra
help to pay for college silver state
schools credit union the sponsors of
this next segment is here to help
mercedes sat down with their ceo to
explain
you know you have some exciting things
going on over at silver state schools
credit union and one thing i want to
talk about is just an incredible program
you have for kids who are wanting to go
to college and as we all know with the
high cost of college tuition these days
students really really need a hand and
silver state school's credit union has
been providing scholarships to students
for decades tell us a little bit about
that um believe it or not we've given
over 800 000 scholarships since 1989 to
this program and one of the questions
mercedes that we're always asked is what
criteria are you looking for and so
sources schools creating is looking for
high school seniors who demonstrate
excellence in academics but more
importantly also how they
how they serve and are good
stewards in our local community through
their extracurricular activities and
community involvement um so this
scholarship application actually runs
through friday march 18th and we
encourage high school seniors parents of
seniors or high school teachers and
their counselors to share a scholarship
link with their eligible students and
for complete details or to apply you can
visit silverstatecu.com
scholarships it's tax season and silver
state schools credit union they can
really help their members assure the
achieve these long-term financial goals
tell us how and at silver state schools
credit union it's important that every
member achieves financial success from
our perspective and so we have
representatives that can assist with
that long-term financial planning
including retirement planning investment
portfolios asset management and even
estate planning believe it or not and so
our knowledgeable reps are always
available to work with anyone who wants
to develop a comprehensive plan or to
review their current plan to ensure that
the path to long-term financial success
is in place how can silver state schools
credit union help someone who wants to
buy a home or take advantage of their
current homes equity there's probably
never been not at least for 10 to 12
years there's not been the equity that
we've had in our homes right now and
that's why we have licensed mortgage
experts to help you finance new home we
have 24-hour
pre-approvals conventional or jumbo loan
programs
lots of down payment options fast
closings and our exclusive home
advantage program which anybody can look
up in our website it's it's a fantastic
program that actually offers members uh
at or or non-members who want to become
members um actually a rebate when they
when they actually purchase their home
and use the mortgage through us and so
we can also assist with refinancing an
existing mortgage to obtain a lower
interest rate and sometimes you know
when we talk about home equities two
mercedes one of the great things you can
do with your home equity is use it for
home improvements consolida consolidate
high interest debt um
something that we just talked about
scholarships uh send your child through
college and use the equity in your home
to do that if that's something that you
want to help with um and and you can
also use it to purchase that large
ticket item that you've been waiting for
thank you again to silver state schools
credit union for sponsoring this segment
give them a call at 702-733-8820
for more information
the batman